eighth season in the National Football
League friend of the program I would
like to call him Harrison Smith how are
you Harrison yeah I kind of I kind of
rag Don Rudi before Harrison disclosure
I'm sorry I heard did you hear it I I
heard that I heard the tail-end hmm
how what do tell me what do you when you
go to Notre Dame what did they tell you
about Rudi
seriously Harrison come on let's let's
put all the cards on the table here one
eight when when you show up on the
campus there what do they tell you about
Rudy officially I thank you I think it's
different for every person like I
actually Rudy came and talked to us okay
when I was like a freshman or sophomore
okay so we heard about we heard about
how awesome it was
but growing up I wasn't another name fan
so I hated the movie to be honest at the
time I shouldn't say that now because
you know you don't own another Dean
doesn't own you know college greatness
or the tingly feeling you get when
there's a underdog story that's not your
own ownership of that Harrison you know
what I'm saying no but I think but I
think it's a great contributor you know
I don't think anyone claims to own it
but you know it's a great underdog story
by the way
and yeah Jon Favreau I mean this is pre
Sanders Favreau and and and Vince Vaughn
I agree with you so did Rudy really get
carried off the field Don Harrison
like for real carried off um I don't
know I I cannot confirm that one of my
buddy's dads was in school at the time
yes and he said that he they didn't even
like when they you know you hear the
Rudy champion everyone
Rudy he said they didn't even know that
what they were saying so okay you know I
think I think you asked how serious that
moment was maybe they were saying boo
they weren't saying Rudy they were
saying boo I mean potentially see Harris
and that's part of the reason why I love
having
on the show is this is real talk I mean
if it's about a movie this is real talk
as far as I'm concerned this is real
talk okay now what's going on with this
Vikings team Harrison Smith walk me
through what a feeling is eighth season
in the NFL so many hopes for a team that
does have a roster that that is
considered Super Bowl worthy Harrison
walk me through this right now just the
feeling around the facilities and work
we're putting in and stuff yeah you know
like you said we do have a lot of
familiar faces especially on the
defensive side of the ball so I think
you know that's a good thing and then
that's also something that we have to
keep pushing each other to not say okay
we've been you know we've been pretty
good for a few years we're just going to
be you know we're gonna be pretty good
again know if we need to kind of take it
to the next level and we're competing
against offense and they're doing some
really good things so it's good to see a
lot of you know just a lot of the
schemes that they're putting together
and we got a ton of playmakers over
there
you know a lot of confidence in the
coaches in the quarterback so I think
we're excited you know the same thing
you're gonna hear from any guy talking
about his own team I'm gonna be biased
so no but I but I really do believe that
about you know the type of guys we have
the type of coaches we have and what is
possible we still have to put in the
work and make the plays when it counts
okay so what's more real the Vikings
Super Bowl chances of Rudy got carried
off the field years ago Harrison is the
present and the future so what do you
what last year eight seven and one what
could you point to last year that you
say this year's going to be different
because we're better at that I mean what
what went down last year you know when
you after you played a few years you
figure out being a playoff team to not
being a playoff team is literally one
play here there
you know if we we beat moon veins at a
time last year already in the playoffs
we make a play and other game we're in
the playoffs and we didn't make those
plays so we're not a playoff team you
can say if we did this than that but it
doesn't matter so the difference is when
you're one of the better teams and
you're not is normally not a huge margin
it's winning when it matters most and
that's what we didn't do last year so
going forward that's you know that's
what we put a lot of emphasis on is
those situations you know two-minute at
the end of the first half or at the end
of the game or the turnover
differentials so you know special teams
hidden yardage they're all those small
things that maybe people or not small
things but they seem small I really
determine the outcome of games which
determines if they're in the playoffs or
not
Harrison Smith four-time Pro Bowl Viking
safety here on the Rich Eisen show your
work in the secondary Harrison is going
to be reviewable by instant replay this
year when it comes to pass interference
your thoughts on that development here I
don't have a ton of thoughts on it yet
you know last year it was uh what it was
roughing the passer deal and that kind
of you know it seemed a little crazy
early on and then I tried got ironed out
so that's kind of what I'm just
expecting for everything going forward I
definitely don't don't like the idea but
you know I'm sure they'll figure it out
what do you think about it I think I'll
be good or bad for the game well by the
way I had loved having the table's
turned on me
that was a cue now on the a as opposed
to the QA Harrison I appreciate the
table turn right there I'm genuinely
concerned that the intention of this
rule which is to make sure an NFC
Championship game gaffe does not happen
again the issue is now is that replay
allows anything that is reviewable to be
reviewed once replay has opened and
nobody no fan is expecting to see if
Harrison Smith has committed defensive
pass interference but we find out that
their receiver is actually pushed off
and now suddenly there's now offsetting
penalties
by rule through replay or switch it's
not defensive it's just offensive not
defensive I'm telling you I'm telling
you I would I would say that this is
entirely possible to happen 12 men on
the field for instance ok Harrison as
you know that here's a good example you
know Aaron Rodgers you know he likes to
quick snap when perhaps one of your
teammates gets off the field a little
bit slower than needs to be and so let's
just say Mike Zimmer says you know what
I think I oughta only 11 men on the
field and that quick snap that led to a
pass break up down the field there was
no free play there so I'm gonna throw a
challenge flag to see if where there's
at 11 or 12 men on the field it comes
back that there were 11 men on the field
but at the end of the play let's just
say I just don't I'm out there rollers
Avery Rhodes committed offensive pass
interference so instead of it being
saving five yards you know you now get a
spot foul I mean this is the sort of
stuff that can absolutely happen
Harrison that's my damn with it I
believe that scenario I was just I'm
just saying they're they're never gonna
overturn a defensive pass interference
to a Norfolk oh so you're saying now
that's the defensive player talking is
what you're saying now I'm picking up
what you're putting down no they would
say though there's gonna be unintended
consequences though stuff that we can't
even imagine right so that that's my
concern on all this front but your your
your your point was well-taken though
about how last year the roughing the
passer stuff got fixed which means I
guess the tweak will come when the
Vikings earn a tie instead of a loss
against the Green Bay Packers is that
what you're saying more pronounced again
okay because we came in you know before
I let you go a lot of conversation about
the NFC North quarterbacks and chugging
beers Harrison where does Kirk Cousins
stand on this in this competition oh
that's a good question you know we we
should probably you should probably
shore that up with him but you
we're not gonna we're not gonna pressure
them into that okay I think it I think
it didn't go as well as some guys hoped
it did for him you know okay
sounded like a good idea right if you're
not good at it you know you probably
should just leave it alone
I know no I mean Aaron cut Nick Walker a
skirt well I mean could Kirk I mean
could he is it is it a does he does he
partake in a beer I mean is that is that
something that he does maybe do a face
time so but is there let's put it this
way that do you think that there is a
correlation between the ability for a
quarterback to slam a beer and win
football games do you think that there
is a direct line all of this I I do I do
not I don't think it's correlated no so
that answers my question that Kirk
Cousins does not slam a beer is wasted
what you're saying or maybe it's
something else like someone else said
they do scotch okay that's true
drinkers choice does look like he sips
instead of slash I'm sure he does
Harrison I always appreciate you our
chats like I've no I tell you good to be
back on right right back at you
as I tell you every single time I always
appreciate the way you play football and
in your honesty you're on the show I
appreciate it
you take care of yourself iris and we'll
chat down the line all right Mike what
you got it that's Harrison Smith Viking
safety at Harry H ARR I Smith 22 on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app